IT IS THE PERFECT JULY, BURSAR
MEN, HERE
IN THEIR HOME WHITES COME AS
THEY SHOULD BE RYAN, CORRECT?
HEAD
COACH, GOT CANCELED, NOT A
SURPRISE HE IS DOING WELL.
TRADED TO BOSTON, WAS
IMMEDIATELY PRODUCTIVE FOR THE
DAVID PASTRNAK.
THE BIG LIE WE TALKED ABOUT,
BEFORE THEHE
GETS IT FREE COME ON BJORK, THE
BRUYNE.
RHONDA, TO THE SIDE.
SKINNER, SHOT, BLOCK OTHER
WAY.
THROWS IT ACROSS, PASTRNAK,
GRAY SHOT, SAVE
TO GET THIS SURGERY WANTS.OMAR.
SKINNER, SHOCKED
I'M NOT A FAN OF THE WAY THEY
HAVE HUNDRED IT
MILLER, TO THE SIDE OF THE NET,
THAT ANGLE SHOT BY THOMPSON.
CAME BOUNCING OFF  PASS OVER TO
COLEMAN, CAN'T  THOMAS KNOWS TH
COYLE.  GOING BACK DOOR.
AN EASY TAP IN FROM  O MARK.
LOOK AT THAT.
RIGHT IT'S THE RIGHT
DYLAN COZENS, HAD A HUGE FIRST.
BACK IN, SAVED BY OMARK.
SENT IT ACROSS TO CHARLIE COYLE
?,  STARTS UP AT
WILL BUTCHER THOUGHT HE HAD ONE
RUNS TO THAT TOP BEAT
TRAFFIC, BUT HE CAN'T.
MARCHAND, GRZELCYK, OFF THE
PO
HIS PARTNER GRZELCYK.
ANDERSON GETS BE, THOSE TWO ARE
TNT, ON WEDNESDAY.ARD
SCORE!
GREAT STICK BY COYLE TO BREAK
UP THAT FIRST PLAY.
STUDENTS OUT TO THE